oh this guess this wall is coming down
look in up you didn't plug in this hard
drive to the one free outlet I have the
main thing is something getting to the
end of the piece for things get a little
messy to say the least
there's just a quality drop I feel well
on one day yeah playing it all like
freeform like Oh we'll figure that out
on the day of that's great for when you
have conversation scenes and some basic
stuff like that when you're dealing with
an action movie can't do that that's
just that's the big thing I learn here
this stuff needed way more planning
needed way more vision it needed the
pre-production time to help support that
it's amazing how much [ __ ] we break down
without the internet you can't get any
work done without Perry King we're
talking about the Internet
I have a comment that I want to be able
to throw on YouTube that I can't because
we don't have internet so I'm like okay
I'll just put the comment on to my phone
and post it there I've you know network
but how do I get it from the computer to
my phone you hit me with it
all right oh you want me okay that's how
you're gonna hit me with him
Undertaker's days next time don't forget
to pay me again oh I got a dog right
here gonna do the back hit Oh gotta help
me clean up that's some bling hit
everyone leaves I got I got all day like
okay so what would I have done
differently Hey as I was started by
planning Wes sorry planning less as in
like attempting less not like less
planning forcing one thing if you want
to sit there and plan things out figured
out being less ambitious for this kind
of stuff because plan for this action
sequence is far too big for what we are
able to pull off how is that coming
across would you want to see more setups
more art direction more like more what
to take a look at what we actually did
shoot what would have made it all better
is simply just doing it straight on full
rehearsal for this action sequence day
would have helped a lot the problem with
the action sequences that you're trying
to do really complex stuff and motions
and things like that
and nobody has any idea what's going on
and by planning a little less you gain a
little time to do that and then suddenly
boom you're shooting a little bit less
but it's all just a little bit better
I'm finding myself just looking at stuff
invisible that's never making it in KC a
little bit of you surgery yeah
sandy you're gonna come back and be like
what did you guys do I saw you guys
breaking that over Jake's head moms in
the background I know everything that
happens in the studio times whoa what'd
you guys do
you broke the wall I can't believe you
guys would do something like that back
to work for me be gentle I think Steve
is and you know figure it out
our landlord he doesn't want us to go on
the roof wait why not
we're not supposed to go up here right
now correct but we're gonna do it
anyways